it's humiliating ruins your life
Nickelodeon's victorious was such a hit
fans were certain that its cast would go
on to achieve a whirlwind of
accomplishments and while that was the
case for a handful of cast members some
of its actors missed the mark by a long
shot for some stars victorious was the
peak of their careers and for others it
was just the beginning keep watching to
find out if the cast's acting career
skyrocketed or plummeted after
victorious aired its final episode in
2013
Vancouver native Avan Jogia is best
known for portraying BEC Oliver on
Victorious Pavan was 18 years old when
he first starred in the Nickelodeon
classic but despite being a fan favorite
Ivan had a hard time retaining that
level of Fame since leaving the show
however that isn't to say that Aven
hasn't been keeping himself busy on top
of starring in a handful of movies and
TV shows ivan co-starred in the movie
the outcasts with victoria justice in
2017 although acting will forever be one
of Alvin's biggest passions the actor
has widened his creative reach and set
his sights on writing and modeling as
well when he was 27 years old
Ivan walked the runway at a Dolce &
Gabbana's show during Milan Men's
Fashion Week in 2017 and just two years
later
Ivan released a book titled mixed
feelings poems and stories during an
interview with Teen Vogue
Ivan revealed that his book talked about
the struggles of the mixed-race
population as of 2020
Ivan has been cast in the upcoming film
the exchange in which he's all set to
play the character Stefan you can't
bring up Ivan Jogi without talking about
elizabeth gillies who played Alvin's
on-screen girlfriend Jade West Elizabeth
did an amazing job of portraying the
misunderstood mean girl Jade and that
did not go unnoticed
since Elizabeth's character was far from
one-dimensional her talents as an actor
came through which opened a lot of doors
for her in 2017 Elizabeth was cast as a
Fallon Carrington in the reboot of
dynasty this show's popularity would go
on to rival the one of Victorious
allowing Elizabeth to create a new name
for herself
Elizabeth's character Jade was on screen
besties with Cat Valentine who was
played by Ariana Grande and fan to the
singer were thrilled to find out that
Ariana and Elizabeth were good friends
in real life in 2018 ariana asked
Elizabeth to star in her music video
thank you next and she accepted the
video took a page out of a Mean Girls
burn book and Elizabeth was transformed
into the film's protagonist Cady heron
as of 2020 Elizabeth continues to star
as Fallon on dynasty but nothing else is
currently in the works in 2010 Matt
Bennett stole our hearts as the shy
creative and hilarious Robbie Shapiro a
mean guy took my left shoe and Rex's but
what is the actor been up to since the
Nickelodeon show wrapped up well turns
out Matt is one of the more successful
victorious actors just like Elizabeth
Matt scored a role in ariana grande's
music video Thank You next
he played cliff pantone eight however
the actor hasn't been in anything since
that same year in 2018 Matt played Gavin
Landers on the unpredictable TV series
American vandal and before that he
appeared in a single episode of Grey's
Anatomy in 2011 when victorious was
still on TV Matt was cast as Helens
stepson in bridesmaids Matt tried his
hand in music too he released an album
titled terminal cases back in 2016
however for the time being Matt appears
to be taking a break from acting to
focus on his career as DJ Matt DJ dat
LA's candy pop in late 2019 and was a
total hit at the time we went to mystic
mountain daniella monet was a sitcom
queen long before she starred as Trina
Vega on Victorious she was 21 years old
when she first played the celebrity
obsessed teenager
daniela started acting when she was 8
years old in 2003 she was cast as Missy
Kleinfeld on the popular sitcom 8 simple
rules
she even appeared in an episode of the
Bernie Mac show in 2004 on top of that
Daniela had a small role in zoey 101 as
well as the suite life of zack & cody
after victorious wrapped up daniela
continued to pursue an acting career and
like the majority of the cast she also
appeared in ariana grande's music video
unfortunately for daniela she hasn't
been able to lock down a lead role since
starring as Trina in 2016
Daniela would play Sam in a total of 10
baby-daddy episodes but that along with
a handful of TV movies and one-time
appearances is all the actors managed to
do but that never fazed the mother of
one who spends most of her time working
on her YouTube channel where she talks
about her other passions like health
fitness and nutrition keep watching to
find out which a victorious star did not
appear in ariana grande's music video
next up is everyone's favorite wacky
teacher mr. sicker wits who is played by
actor Eric Lang if you didn't think much
of sicko woods back then think again
because this guy was already a pretty
big deal in the industry Eric Lang has
been acting since the late 90s before
joining the cast of Victorious eric
appeared in big-time productions like
lost and weeds
however eric had trouble finding a
long-term character that he could stick
with that is until he made waves at
Hollywood Arts as mr. sicko wits from
2010 to 2013 but that was just the
beginning for Eric Lang who would use
victorious as a stepping-stone for
success Eric would go on to portray
detectives on shows like unbelievable
and Perry Mason and he would even
portray bills Stegner on the popular TV
series narcos as of 2020 eric has been
cast in the upcoming movie Antebellum
and is set to play Liu Burke in the
upcoming TV series a brand new cherry
flavour but not every victorious cast
member was as fortunate as Eric
who could forget about Andre Harris the
talented singer-songwriter and musician
who became Tori vega's first friend at
Hollywood Arts Andre was played by Leon
Thomas and both the actor and his
character had a lot in common for one
they both enjoy acting and secondly
they're both multi-talented and have a
passion for music since parting ways
with his victorious cast mates Leon has
managed to keep his acting career afloat
while focusing on his career as a rapper
in 2017 Leon portrayed Darrel in the
movie Detroit and would go on to have
small roles in TV shows like
satisfaction and insecure but he never
found a claim like he did with
victorious acting career aside Leon
followed his musical passions and proved
to be more successful in that domain he
has collaborated with rappers like Wiz
Khalifa and post Malone on top of
releasing his EP Genesis in 2018
Leon helps his former co-star ariana
grande write songs for her album yours
truly
then there's Michael Eric Reed who is
best known for playing ass engine van
Cleef on Victorious hey girls
despite trying his hardest Michael never
succeeded in ditching the Nickelodeon
image and struggled to find a lasting
role
Michael was last cast in the 2019 movie
Bob Freeman exterminator for hire in
which he played the vampire Lord however
Michael has no upcoming projects in the
works his Instagram page proves that
Michael has chosen to follow other
endeavors for now like promoting his
presidential candidate for the US
elections
Michael hasn't given up on acting though
but he might have switched his focus
from movies and TV shows to theater
productions he still plays music and
isn't afraid to stick out from the crowd
Michael's acting career hasn't been as
successful as the rest of the victorious
cast but either way the odd yet lovable
Sinjin seems to be doing just fine
disco Victoria Justice was just 16 years
old when she snagged the lead role of
Tori Vega in victorious what's your name
I'm 16 back then she had no way of
knowing that her acting career would
stall shortly after the series wrapped
up production fans thought that Victoria
would become a household name in no time
she had the brains the talent and the
beauty after all but after victorious
things were an uphill battle for the
actor who had find it hard to ditch her
Nickelodeon image and make a name for
herself in Hollywood in 2015 Victoria
played Lindy Sampson on the TV series
eye candy which would bring her little
recognition but besides starring
alongside ah've and Jogia in the
outcasts Victoria would fail to snag
big-time roles Victoria is one of the
few victorious cast members to not
appear in ariana grande's music video
and this is due to her and Ariana
butting heads after the show concluded
its run every movie Victoria was cast in
from then on turned out to be a total
flop which would render her unconscious
would then go on to accuse ariana of
being a scene stealer and an article in
Seventeen magazine would go on to peg
Victoria as a bully
despite ariana grande's greatest efforts
to discredit the rumor the very notion
that Victoria and Ariana were at odds
harmed Victoria's career
seeing as Ariana had a slew of dedicated
fans on top of that Victoria would try
to pursue a musical career in 2013 which
would also flop and leave the actor
pigeon-holed as of 2020 Victoria is cast
in the upcoming movie push we hope that
this project turns her acting career
around and last but certainly not least
is the triple threat ariana grande
ariana starred as the innocent and sweet
Cat Valentine
best friend to Jade West ariana managed
to ditch her child actor label faster
than the rest of her cast mates however
when it comes to ariana grande's acting
career we can pretty much say that it
peaked on the set of the nickelodeon
show shortly after Victoria's aired its
final episode ariana continued on with
her character on the set of salmon cat
but after the show wrapped up in 2014
Ariana set out to create a new name for
herself as one of the most famous
singers in the
world everyone knows the name ariana
grande even if they've never seen an
episode of victorious in their lives in
2015 ariana would play channel number
two for episodes of scream queens she
would also make cameo appearances in
movies like Zoolander 2 and Men in Black
International ariana is still friends
with the majority of the victorious cast
with the exception of Victoria Justice
and that's a wrap
who was your favorite victorious actor
tell us in the comments thanks for
watching for more awesome content be
sure to subscribe to the things and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up on your way out we'll catch
you next time